explíquenos en qué punto se inició esta
disputa por el mercado de la coca
para ser que nosotros
en algún momento con el anterior
gobierno fuimos impuestos con una ley
906 en la cual en esa ley se estipula
claramente que en bolivia existen
solamente dos mercados la de sacaba de
cochabamba y la de la paz adepcoca
departamental de los yungas de la paz el
gobierno
autorizado no son las excedentarias son
las rojas el cultivo de coca ahora no
teniendo donde justificar el comercio el
comercio y el consumo de esa coca de las
zonas excedentarias
quiere violar y esa ley que nos
impusieron y quiere negociar lo ilegal
para hacer funcionar ese mercado
clandestino
apadrinado por el gobierno afectando los
intereses y la economía de los
productores de posibles de la paz de la
zona original eje ancestral
y es posible ahora que el gobierno
consiga a llegar a un acuerdo que
contente a todas las partes
prácticamente las autoridades que
corresponde llámese ministerios
ministerios no han tenido la capacidad
para poder llegar a una solución a
nuestra demanda lo cual dejamos sin
manos debe de nuestra primera autoridad
de presidente revisarse catacora para
que nos pueda dar esa solución a nuestra
demanda de lo contrario el día lunes 22
de agosto
vamos a radicalizar nuestras protestas y
en adelante todo lo que suscite será
responsable en los ministros de arias y
el presidente porque cabe aclarar que
hemos mandado más de 36 notas durante
todo este tiempo para dar solución a
nuestra demanda y en un contexto en que
la discusión sobre la legalización de la
coca avanza en el continente ve usted
posible a futuro una ampliación de los
mercados legales dentro de la propia
bolivia
prácticamente hay una ley que limita
pero el gobierno está violando esa ley
al autorizar el cultivo de coca en zonas
excedentarias donde no corresponde el
gobierno ha dado su autorización ahora
no tiene la justificación
para poder hacer el comercio que
corresponde afectando a la zona
originaria y ancestral que tiene esa
organización dentro de la norma tiempo
la ley ahora el gobierno quiere
inventarse ese tercer mercado a nivel
nacional para justificar su consumo lo
cual el país entero sabe que esa época
no se consume no llega al comercio al
contrario el gobierno está fomentando al
narcotráfico